Hello everyone
and welcome to lecture six of CMI 296.
So today is a very exciting day because
we'll be talking about how to
train a model in practice
a text to image generation model.
And as you know
the first half of this class was all
about preparing the foundational
theoretical foundations for us to be
able to do that. And in this second
part, we'll be really talking about more
the practical aspects.
And
today will be no exception.
So as usual
before we start, we're going to just
recap what we saw last time.
So if you remember
last lecture, we saw the main image
generation architectures and we started
with
a big one, the U-Net, which was trendy
up until 2022.
And we saw that among the things we
wanted to see in an image generation
model
we wanted a model that was able to
understand the global structure of an
image
also capture the local details
able to receive external signals, for
instance the condition
and be computationally tractable.
And we saw that the U-Net
was relying on an inductive bias
which was something that was reflected
by the convolution operation
which is mimicking how humans
look at pictures.
And we saw that the U-Net was composed
of two main phases.
The first one is the downsampling phases
where we put
an input a noisy latent that we then
perform convolution operations and
downsampling operations so that we can
get a bigger receptive field that would
enable us to have a global understanding
of the input in the bottleneck.
So that was the first phase and then the
second phase was the upsampling
phase
which was composed of upsampling
operations for instance the transpose
convolution
where we were able to get back to
the dimension
of interest which is the same dimension
as the input
and we saw that there are these
copy and crop connections
that were allowing us to transport the
local details that were able to compute
in the downsampling phase
and couple that with the global
understanding that we had the global
structure understanding that we had
from the bottleneck.
So that was a unit.
We saw that the unit was great
but
the unit had a failure case which was
that there was no direct connection
between different local parts of the
image
and for an example such as someone
looking at oneself in the mirror
you need to be aware of the local
details from two different parts of the
image.
So this was motivating us to look at
another architecture
which is the diffusion transformer
which was published in 2022 late 2022
which relies on the concept of
self-attention
where each patch of the latents attends
to one another allowing these direct
connections to form.
And as a result,
we were able to have this concern
mitigated.
And we also saw a way to inject
conditions into the architecture. So,
we spent some time on the adapt adaptive
layer normalization
which was taking the condition and the
time step as inputs that was
modulating the token embeddings
via these gates shift and scale factors.
And we also saw that there were very
many variants actually. It was not just
the diffusion transformer. There were
many variants of the diffusion diffusion
transformer such as the multi-modal
diffusion transformer which is now more
trendy.
Which was looking at making the input
text
as a stand-alone modality
that was being injected as input as
opposed to an afterthought via the
modulation.
Mainly because
the adaptive layer norm was injecting
the condition across all patch
embeddings
in a uniform way.
And we didn't want to have that. So, we
also saw the MM DIT.
And of course
these architectures are not the only
ones that are out there. There are many
variations.
So, hopefully that lecture
was a lecture that
gave you the intuitive tools to at least
understand why certain components are
used.
All good on this? So, this was last
lecture.
We also saw the timeline so which I
briefly mentioned here. So units largely
dominated the early 2020s if I can say
it like this.
And then the DIT based models are
dominating
uh the architectures that are coming up
nowadays.
From
end of 2022 2022 onwards.
And what are we going to do today?
Today, we're going to focus
on
practical applications on how we can
actually train a text-to-image
generation model.
And I know so far we have seen different
components of that overall
system.
We've seen
the actual backbone that is allowing us
to denoise
the noisy latents which is for instance
here a DIT based model.
We've seen that there's also another
model involved, the VAE,
which is allowing us to
have a latent space in which we can
operate
which lowers the computational burden
of our training process and generation
process.
And we've also seen that there were
there were multiple models we could use
that could embed conditions that we
would then
have as input.
So to be clear,
today we're going to focus on how to
train
the image generation model itself.
And we're not going to focus on the VAE
and
the embedding models.
So just for reference, we will actually
dig into embedding models
next week with the multimodal LLMs.
But I'm going to just push it for next
week. More on that, too.
Cool.
So,
let's start.
And I just first want us to look at this
whole problem
at a very high level.
And in particular, look at the overall
process that allows us to go from
an initial initialized model
to a model that is able to work in
production.
So, the first step, you know, we have
our image generation model.
We first teach it
how to
generate images, like any images.
This phase is typically called the
pre-training phase and is quite
compute-intensive.
It involves a lot of data and a lot of
work on the data side.
So, that's number one. And it's a phase
that's all models go through.
Then,
we have a second stage
that is called the
post-training stage
where we take that pre-trained model
that already knows how to generate
images
and we teach it how to generate
good images.
And we will see what good means.
We could also
optionally also personalize our model to
generate specific kinds of images. And
we will see this optional third step,
which is here called tuning.
And then,
at the end of this lecture, we'll also
look at how we can actually make our
model be able to work in production in
an efficient way.
And here, we will look at distillation
models
or distillation methods, I should say,
that
allow our model
to generate samples in fewer steps.
Cuz we've seen that usually these image
generation models, they're
working in an iterative fashion.
So, you always have to
have one the initial noise as input to
get the let's say vector field and then
iterate on that
many times potentially and here we want
to shorten
the amount of times we need to do that
so that we can make this process just
less costly
and reduce the latency, which is
typically what we care about
for production use cases.
Everyone good with the
big
big steps?
So,
we'll start with the first
even before starting actually,
we'll be talking about
the loss that we will use
for our training process
and
I think you already know what the loss
is because we've spent the first three
lectures talking about three different
perspectives
on getting to that stage.
So, here this part is mainly around
just all agreeing on what those losses
are
and see what are the changes that happen
in practice to these losses
to make the training process more
optimized and you will see what I mean.
So, first
I'm going to recap
what we saw during the three pre
first lectures.
So, the first one if you recall what was
diffusion with DDPM
where
our
uh thought process was we take clean
images that we corrupt
step by step. So, you have this XT
that is a function of the clean image
and the noise that you add.
And we saw that we could derive a
tractable loss and you end up with
a formula that is allowing you to
denoise
the noise
with the formula uh on the slides
by parameterizing
a model that is geared towards
predicting the noise to remove, epsilon
theta.
And here the loss is as follows. So,
it's the expectation of
just the L2 distance between
your predicted noise to remove and the
actual noise that was added.
And it's an expectation over
the time steps,
the clean images that are part of your
training sets,
and then the noise that is typically
sampled from a Gaussian distribution.
Then in lecture two, we had this second
perspective of looking at the same
problem, which was
okay, in order to recover clean images,
let's actually look at
where the clean clean images are
by estimating the score,
which is acting like a compass.
And here we saw that there was a
stochastic differential equation way of
putting this, which was given by DX is
equal to some drift term and some
diffusion term along with the
continuous noise, which was the Wiener
process.
So, this was the forward process and
then the reverse process was something
that
was popping up the score.
And this just highlighted the fact that
we needed to estimate the score in order
to denoise
into clean images.
And here
the loss
was an expectation
over
the score that you wanted to estimate
minus the actual score of the noise
distribution.
So, that's the second loss that we saw.
And then the third perspective, which
was lecture three,
was the flow perspective,
where we said
that in order to go from noise to our
target distribution, we're going to
interpret that problem as a transport
problem.
And here we focused on
the velocity, or also known as the
vector field,
that
could be used using an ODE solver like
the Euler method.
And we had a loss
that was regressing the vector field
by just taking
two
points. So, one from the target
distribution, X1, and then X0 from
the noisy distribution, to be clear,
Gaussian distribution.
And we ended up with
this loss function.
Now, one thing I want to say,
and maybe I've said it
sometime in the past,
nowadays, people mainly focus on the
flow matching perspective.
So, I just want us to all be aligned
that moving forward,
by default, we'll be using the flow
matching loss
as the default loss.
Does that sound good?
So, let's look at this loss.
So, here what we're doing
is we're optimizing on the parameters
theta
such that we minimize the loss on the
slides.
In particular, by taking the expectation
over
time steps,
data points in the training data, so P
data,
and over
noisy observations that are part of a
Gaussian distribution.
And in particular,
we are taking So, we were saying we were
taking T
drawn from from a uniform distribution.
And I just want us to pause
on this statement and see if this
actually makes sense.
But first, just as a reminder, here by
T, we mean
the noise level,
where T equals zero corresponds
to a lot of noise.
T equal to one
means no noise at all.
And T somewhere in between means
a little bit noisy.
So,
I'm going to ask you some questions.
So, let's suppose
we want to
figure out
from an input that is extremely noisy,
so think of it as X0,
whether making a prediction on where to
go from X0
is
an easy or a hard task. And so, I'm just
going to make our life easier. So, if
you remember the illustration we had, so
we have the noisy distribution that is
the one on the left, and then the target
distribution on the right. So, what
we're saying is if we sample
a noisy latent that is very noisy,
is the task of predicting where to go an
easy task or a hard task?
Yeah, easy?
Do you want to say easy?
Yes. So, it's indeed easy. Like now, why
is it easy?
So,
at the very beginning, the input that
you have
is actually
void of all information. You don't know
anything
about
where you're going. So,
what your model will be incentivized to
do will be to just
try to predict
if you want the average
direction where you need to go.
So, regardless of how much time you
spend learning that, it will just learn
roughly where to go, which will be if
you want the mean of where all the
observations in your target data
distribution are.
So, no matter how much time you spend in
that region of noise,
you will be incentivized to predict the
mean of where all the observations are.
So, that's why I say it's an easy task.
Okay. So, now how about if T is close to
one, meaning that
we're already very, very advanced in the
denoising process, and there is almost
no noise left. Is it a
an easy task or a hard task to to know
where to go from there?
Hard?
Yeah.
Okay, so we have one hard.
Yep.
Easy again?
Okay, so let's see. Um
so let's try to think.
So when T close to one,
what that means is that the input XT
is already
almost clean.
So we're almost there.
So what that means is you only need to
make a few tweaks to little details
to have a fully denoised image.
And in that sense,
it is actually an easy task because you
already have an image that is almost
clean.
And so on the illustration, it
corresponds to
if your
um
if your observation is already part of
the target data distribution and you
just need to do
a small step towards having your final
observation.
Okay, so let's do the last one.
How about if your input image is not
super super super noisy?
It's not almost clean.
It's somewhere in the middle.
Is the task easy? Is the task of knowing
where to go easy or hard?
Yep.
A hard and same here.
Okay, so yeah, you're completely right
uh and
to illustrate the point that you're
saying, we are indeed
in this space at a point where we need
to figure out about where to go.
But even thinking about it from an
intuitive perspective,
let's assume
that your target distribution is
composed of images of teddy bears.
If you're in the middle,
then it means that you that you know
roughly
what the body is like, what the head is
like, you know a little bit where the
arms like, but there's a lot of things
that you need to figure out about where
to place. You need to
figure out what kind of texture you want
your teddy bear to develop, you need to
to put the eyes, you need to put a bunch
of things.
And these are all
hard decisions that you need to take
at time steps that are typically in the
middle.
And for that reason,
t equal to 0.5 is a hard
hard task for the model.
So,
if you remember,
what we saw
was that we were drawing our time step
when computing the loss
from a uniform distribution.
So, what that means is
we're asking our model to try to be good
at predicting the targets as many times
for easy tasks
as much as for hard tasks.
And this is the reason why, in practice,
people actually do not
sample the time step from a uniform
distribution.
They actually sample from
another distribution, which we're going
to see in a second,
that emphasizes on middle steps
more than it emphasizes on either the
early or the late late steps.
And the distribution that uh
like people in general use typically is
called the logit normal distribution.
So,
the formula on the slide may look scary,
but it's actually quite simple.
So, what we're saying is
So, first of all, I'm going to define
what logit means.
So,
the logit
of a quantity, so let's suppose the
logit of our time step t
is defined as the log of t
over 1 minus t
as follows.
And so, t is
between 0 and 1.
So, if t is between 0 and 1,
then logit of t
is anywhere between minus infinity to
plus infinity.
And what we're saying is
if we sample
x
from a normal distribution,
which is between minus infinity and plus
infinity,
then
if we express t
as a function of x,
which
I'm looking at the time we
we'll probably not do,
you will have something like this,
which is just a sigmoid.
And that quantity
will have a distribution that will be
really centered in the middle.
So, you may ask me, well, why do you not
sample directly t
from a normal distribution?
Maybe it's a question you ask, but the
reason why you don't do that is the
normal distribution is a distribution
that can take any values, and you only
want values between 0 and 1.
So, that mathematical trick
is just a way for you to guarantee
that you're in between
0 and 1, because here
the sigmoid is between zero and one.
Does that make sense?
Okay, great. I just want this formula or
this distribution to not
seem like it's coming out of nowhere.
So,
the good thing with this distribution is
you can tweak the way the distribution
is shaped.
So, you can play with the mean and the
standard deviation. So, you can shift it
towards the time steps that you care
about. So, for instance, if you in your
use case care about I don't know, the
later steps, you can do that.
And so, that is the reason why people
use that distribution.
But, I'm not done with time steps.
There's another thing I want to talk to
you about.
So, we're talking about noise levels.
But, what we actually care about
is how much noise
is perceived by yourself. So, if you
take
the same image, one in low resolution
and the other one in high resolution.
And if you apply the same amount of
noise,
which from the slide, I hope you can see
that the one on the left, the low
resolution one, feels more noisy than
the one on the right.
So, same image,
different resolution but same noise
level, the one on the left feels more
noisy than the one on the right.
So, something tells you that
you also need to take that into account
in some way.
So, right now we're not taking that into
account,
but not for long.
So, you will see that in papers, there
is this concept of time step shifting
as a function of resolution.
Where the idea is to rescale the noise
level
in a way that reflects the perceived
noise
that you see.
And so I just want to pause on this
concept for a second.
Why would you perceive like
a low resolution image would be more
noisy than a high high resolution one
for the same noise level? Why would you
have to do that? Or why would you think
that?
Well,
there is one thing with images, which is
that
they have a lot of spatial correlation.
Meaning for a given pixel,
you have you you are very likely to have
pixels around it that have the same
value
or the same color.
And so remember that when you add your
noise,
you're adding Gaussian noise
with mean zero.
So what that means is if you have
very few pixels when you're in low
resolution,
then if
the pixel that is responsible for let's
say the color that characterizes how
good your image looks, let's say at a
particular angle,
if that one gets noise,
then
you're losing that information. You're
not able to see it anymore.
But in the high resolution case,
you have multiple pixels surrounding
that region.
So even if one gets noise, the other one
gets noise the other way because
remember that the mean should be equal
to zero, the mean of the noise added
noise should be equal to zero.
You will still have an average value
that will reflect
the underlying pixels
much more
compared to the low resolution case.
So, for that reason
I hope the statement that I'm making,
which is
for a given noise level
things feel more noisy for low
resolution images compared to high
resolution ones, I hope that one is
intuitive.
I'm going to pause for a second. Does
everyone agree with my statement?
Yeah?
Okay.
So
there's again a very scary formula on
the on the slides.
Um the reason why it's there
is just to show you how how people shift
time steps in practice.
So, I would first want us to look at the
chart on the right.
So, you see
TN
and TM.
So, here
let's assume you have two images.
One of resolution N
and the other one of of resolution M
where N is smaller than M.
So
here
for a given TN
you would want to have
a higher TM
because
for a low resolution image
for a given noise level
you would want that noise level to be
higher for the high resolution image for
the perceived noise to be the same.
So, that is what this formula is saying.
But, I know it's not intuitive. So, what
we'll do is we'll take
we'll take 10 10 minutes to try to
understand what that is about.
So
the formula on the slide
is all about reflecting
the change in uncertainty of pixel
values that are noise under different
resolutions.
So, let's assume
that we have
an image.
So, you can think of it as like this.
With uh
Okay, I'm being quick.
So, you have some, let's say, height
and some width.
And let's say that N
So, let's say M
is this one.
And let's say you have a smaller image
with, let's say, H little H and little
W.
And N
is equal to H * W.
Just saying that N
is a lower resolution than M.
That's just what I want to say.
So, here
what we want to do is to try to quantify
the uncertainty
of what the underlying pixel values are
in the case where we have noise
for both cases.
So, what I propose to do is to just
assume
that these images
let's assume that they all have a
certain value
as pixels. So, pixels have three
channels. Let's assume here that we have
only one channel, one value per by
component.
So, here let's assume that each of these
is, let's say, equal to some value C
that is constant.
So far so good?
So, let's assume
that
for a given, let's say, index I that
tells you about
where you are in the image.
And for a given noise level T,
the value
at that index
is something that is given
as a function of C,
the value of your pixel,
and the amount of noise
that you're adding to it.
So, here I just need to put the
noise level.
So,
I told you in lecture one that people
use different conventions for time
steps.
And it just happens
that the formula here in the paper here,
they used the reverse convention
when it comes to time steps. And in
particular, they used T = 0 means
clean,
and T = 1 means
noise.
Which is Which is the opposite of
what usually people do. But,
in order for us to be consistent and end
up on the at the same formula,
we will just assume that that is the
convention that we're going to use.
So, here what we're going to say is
it's 1 - TC
+ T epsilon.
Does everyone agree with me? So, this is
the value
of the noise pixel
at the noise level T.
So, here epsilon is drawn from
a normal distribution.
And so, what can we say about this one?
So,
we assume that this quantity is a
constant,
but we don't know what that quantity is
when we look at an image.
So, our goal here
is to quantify the uncertainty
if we were to estimate C, which is a
constant.
So, what I'm going to do
is to try to quantify the uncertainty of
C.
So, here
just because we have
N elements, so M here and N here, N
elements,
I'm just going to leverage the fact that
we have these N elements
to take the average
over all pixel values.
So, I'm going to sum over
let's say I, my index, that's between
one and the number of pixels,
of the ZIT,
and I'm going to call this
uh ZT bar for average.
So, here this thing is a constant, so it
doesn't move.
And this thing just gets
So, here I'm going to write this here.
plus the average.
So, I'm going to put the T here.
The sum of Y from Sorry, sorry. The sum
of I from one to N
of the epsilons, which are
as a function of I.
Cuz the noise here is different from one
pixel to another.
So, here what I wrote is that the
average value
of a pixel is minus t
times c
plus
t over n of the sum of the noise values.
So, you're going to see why I did that.
So, here I just want to remember our
to remind you of our objective. Our
objective is to
quantify the uncertainty
in estimating c.
So, I want us to
first see that
z t bar
is equal to a constant
plus a sum
of independent Gaussian variables.
So, what you can see about what you can
say about this
this quantity is that
its mean is 1 minus t
times c.
And its variance, let's see.
So, t over n
is a constant.
So, the variance of a constant is just a
constant squared.
And then the variance of each epsilon i
is 1.
And you're adding n of them.
So, it's n
times 1.
Which is
t squared over n.
Okay, great.
So,
why am I doing all of this? I just want
to remind all of us that what we know
what we want is to estimate the
uncertainty of c.
So, what is a good estimator for C?
So, C
here we see that
Z T bar is equal to 1 - T * C plus
something where the mean is zero.
So, a good estimate of C could be
1 over 1 - T
times
Z T bar.
And what we want to quantify is the
uncertainty in estimating C.
So, what is the uncertainty around
estimating C?
So, this thing is a constant.
So, the variance of a constant is just
So, sorry. The variance of a factor in
front of something else is the constant
squared
times the variance of this one, which is
T squared over N.
So, what we're saying
is
that the standard deviation
of our estimate
is equal to the square root of the
variance,
which is T over 1 - T
times 1 over square root of N.
So, what does that mean?
That means that
the uncertainty that we have
around determining what the pixel value
underlying pixel value is
is a function of
1 over
the square root of the resolution.
So, as we increase the resolution N,
that uncertainty gets smaller.
And so, in order to get that
derivation which I don't think I will do
it's just some math.
You would just
equal that uncertainty
for n.
So it's t
under subscript n here.
And you do the same for m.
So you get exactly so the noise level at
time step uh for resolution m
will be
as follows.
And the
goal that we have
is to determine
the time step for resolution m
such that the uncertainty of determining
the pixel value is the same.
So you just need to take these two
quantities.
And just say that
they need to be equal.
And you find tm as a function of tn.
Does that make sense?
So
the low level derivation is not that
important.
What is important is just the mindset
which is
that here we want to shift the time step
for higher resolution
such that we match
this perceived noise that we have.
And so hopefully when you take a look at
that formula you're not
you're not thinking, "Okay, where does
that come from?"
Okay, cool. So I think we're done with
the time steps. Any questions on on
this.
Yep.
What is C again? So, the question is
what is C again? So, this this was
actually a toy example that we had where
we said
let's assume that we have an image
where all the pixel values are constant,
all equal to C.
So, C is the value of the pixel that is
across our image in this toy example.
And
the only problem with C we know it's
constant, but we don't know what C is
because we have noise that image.
And this whole derivation
is about quantifying
our
uncertainty of what C is
if we were to estimate it.
And what we said was
that we could quantify the uncertainty
through the standard deviation.
And what we said was depending on the
resolution at which you're operating
that uncertainty is higher or lower. And
in particular, that uncertainty is lower
as the resolution gets higher.
And this is all because you can actually
perform your estimation by averaging
across all pixel values which are
getting
bigger and bigger when the resolution
increases.
Does that make sense?
Okay, perfect.
Yep.
So, the question is we said that the
diffusion process is taking place in the
latent space, so M and N are in the
latent space. Yes.
Yep.
Okay, perfect.
Let's move on.
We're done with the time steps. Now,
we're going to the next training trick
that I wanted to talk about which is
helping our
our model
with learning representations
faster.
And how do we want to do that?
So, here the whole idea
is to leverage the representation
that some already pre-trained encoders
have learned
and incorporate that
and incentivize our model
to match that representation.
So, in other words, it's as if you want
to learn about a topic
and I come and and and get you a book
about the topic. So, and you can learn
faster about the topic. So, it's exactly
the same mindset.
So, here REPA is the name of the method.
It it stands for representation
alignment.
And it consists
of
coupling your loss
with a loss that reflects how similar
the representations that you're
obtaining within
your diffusion transformer is
with respect to what the pre-trained
encoder is giving you.
So, that's what REPA is about.
So, let's go step by step.
Here we mentioned the L loss for REPA,
but we have not seen what that loss is.
So, we're going to see now.
So, here what we're saying is
in the diffusion transformer
you have
several layers.
So, what you're saying is you're taking
the encoded output of a given layer.
So, let's call that
HT.
And here N, I believe, uh represents the
patch. Let's say for given patch N.
And let's project that
on a space
where we can compare
the
equivalent clean patch representation
from the pre-trained encoder.
And then have a similarity operation
between the two.
So in other words,
we will be penalizing our model
for having a projection of the included
output of a given patch that is noise.
We'll penalize our model from
this being dissimilar from the
representation of
given by the pre-trained encoder of that
same patch,
but cleaned.
So, why do we do that? So as I
mentioned, we're giving a book
to someone who's learning about a topic
so that they can learn faster. And
that's exactly what happens.
So what we're seeing with this strategy
is that it speeds up training
significantly.
Uh so here on the order of 18 times. So
this graph represents
some measure of how good your images are
as a function of the training iteration.
And
what the authors did was just try out a
bunch of different
um
They tried a bunch of things. So they
tried different models, they tried
different layers, they tried
so they did a lot of ablation studies.
One of the things that they saw was
if you were
to perform that loss on the embedding
from earlier layers,
then you actually get better results.
I just want to pause
on that statement for a bit just to
understand why that is the case.
So,
our diffusion transformer
gets to
compute
a prediction of where it wants to go.
And in that sense,
the later layers
may actually
involve
more local details rather than a
semantic representation
of where you want to go.
And so here we know that pre-trained
encoders,
I mean, some of them,
what they're good at is representing
things in a semantically meaningful way.
And so one can understand
this fact by saying that, "Okay, we
actually want
the representation from a layer that is
supposed to output something that is
semantically meaningful to align with a
semantic
a semantically meaningful
representation."
I just wanted to vocalize
a possible interpretation.
And then the last thing I will say is
that an interesting thing is that the
bigger your model, the faster
or the more benefits you have from from
this method.
Cool. And RePa was
published in 2024, but it is a technique
that I have personally seen in a lot of
new papers, so
worth keeping in mind.
And that is concluding
the
first preliminary parts. So now we're
going to first start the first step of
the life cycle training life cycle,
which is pre-training.
And so as a reminder, in this first
step,
the goal is to teach our model how to
generate just images.
And so here
there is a lot of work that goes into
what kind of images you want your model
to learn from.
And so, I just have this one slide,
which is coming from so it's an image
from the Quen technical report, which
just tells you that this is a very
time-consuming work that's uh
involves data data pipeline with a bunch
of filtering different resolutions,
cleaning, and so on. So,
I just have one slide to illustrate
this, but it's a very time-consuming
step. So, just know that this is an
important part of the process.
There is a concept that I want to talk
to you about, which is called curriculum
learning,
which is about
teaching your model
on things in a progressive manner on the
scale of difficulty.
So, in other words, here what we want is
to teach first our model on doing the
easy things
before doing the hard things.
And this is a practice that is typically
something that people do
as this just helps the model learn
better.
And so, here by easy I mean
low-resolution images that are of very
easy aspect ratio, so fixed square you
can think of that. And then the input
text is simple and short. So, for
instance, a teddy bear.
And then the hard part is if you want to
predict something that is of high
resolution, different aspect ratios,
it's not a square anymore.
And then your prompt can be much much
more complicated,
such as the one on the slides.
And now you may ask me, well, how would
you handle images of different
resolutions?
And so, I want us to remember that
the default architectures these days are
DIT based.
And in DIT, what you do is you divide
your input into patches
where each patch
is equivalent to some embedding.
And so what happens is for low
resolution, you will have a certain
number of patches, some number of number
of tokens.
And for high resolution, you will just
have more tokens.
Yes, exactly. So yeah, that's exactly
that. It's as if it was large context.
And if you remember
the length T
will be I, which is the dimension of an
input, so if it's a square over P
squared.
So that's the
order of magnitude to have in mind. I
will
go ahead and move on to the second step
of the training life cycle, which is the
post-training step.
And so here
what we want to do is to teach our model
on how to generate good images.
Now, you may tell me what what does good
means? What does what does good mean?
Uh well, you have of course several
angles, but I will talk about two main
names that you will see out there.
The first one is called continued
training, CT,
which is around teaching your model
on a bunch of
other things that you may care about it
in your task of interest.
So I'll give you an example. So let's
suppose you have a model that has been
pre-trained on a bunch of nature images
and cars and
and uh and so on. But
what you want to do is to have a model
that generates images of teddy bear.
Well, what you'll do here is you will
have a data set
of what you care about, and here that is
teddy bears,
and you will just continue your training
on that data set.
So, that part you can think of it as
focusing on increasing your knowledge.
Then you have another category of
post-training methods, which are called
supervised fine-tuning.
Same thing,
but
here the mindset is to focus on the
behavior of your model
as opposed to increasing the knowledge.
So, in that case, what that means is
generating an image that is more
aesthetically pleasing, that has better
lighting, or it just follows the text
better.
So, these are the kinds of dimensions
that you care about.
And
up until now,
we've only seen how to teach our model
on what to do,
but we have not taught our model on what
not to do.
And that is the objective of the second
category of methods,
which is preference tuning methods,
where for a given prompt,
you may have two images where one of
those images is something that you want
to happen
more than another one.
So, here I will illustrate an example of
the left image, which is uh image of a
teddy bear reading, very high
resolution, good lighting, and
aesthetically pleasing, and the one on
the right, which is uh not as
aesthetically pleasing.
And what you want to do is to
incentivize your model
to generate an image
that is more aligned
with human preferences.
So, here the thumbs up
and thumbs down
are typically either human ratings or
some measure that you can obtain with
some model that we will talk about next
lecture.
But, you you will need to have some
measure of
pairwise comparison or listwise
comparison of different images.
And in this case, the left image being
better than the right one.
So, how do you do that?
So, before we move further,
I just want to say
that the field is still a developing
field.
And
that
next to it,
there's also the text field, the LLM
field that has been growing.
And so, one observation is that you will
find
the same kinds of techniques that are
used
in the LM space
be adapted for the text to image
generation space.
And that is something that I'm going to
show you in the slides
uh that will follow.
So, the first methods
that is around tuning your model
to
incentivize
generating images
that are more aligned with human
preferences is a method called reward
feedback learning.
So, I'll go step by step into what it
does.
So, as I mentioned, what you do is
you take a prompt,
and then you have a bunch of images
related to that prompt.
And what you do is you try to get some
sense of which one is better than the
other.
So, you can either get pairwise ratings
or even listwise ratings.
So, for instance, A is better than B
than C, etc.
And from there,
the idea is to train a reward model
that takes in
a prompt
and an image
and that gets you a score
that tells you how good that image was
with respect to the score
or how good that image was with respect
to the prompt.
And so, here we will not go through the
math. Uh so, in case you're interested,
we actually have a whole lecture on that
in our sister class
uh CME 295.
But, long story short is that you can
use a pairwise loss
based on
um formulation called the Bradley-Terry
formulation
and train a model that does that for
you.
So, at the end of this step,
you get a reward model
that takes in a prompt, that takes in an
image and that tells you how good that
image was to this prompt.
So,
what you care about
is to tune your text-to-image
generation model
to produce images
that are of
higher rewards.
Because the reward model that you
trained
is something that hopefully
aligns with human preferences.
So, if the reward model says that one is
good, then
hopefully it's something that is aligned
with what the human would say.
And what you want
is
to train your image generation model
in order to
produce images that are of higher
rewards.
So, there is some math involved, but at
a very high level, what we do is
we take the noisy latent,
we predict or regenerate an image
for which we have the rewards.
But in this case, the good thing is
that we have the model. We have the
reward model. It is a reward model that
we have at our disposal.
So, it is actually something that is
differentiable.
And so, here you can back propagate
the loss or the objective that you have,
which is to maximize those rewards,
back into your image generation model
in order to incentive incentivize that
model to produce
images that are of higher rewards.
So, that is reward feedback learning.
The second method I will introduce is
called flow group reward policy
optimization,
aka flow GRPO.
So, for those of you who are also in the
LLM field, you may have heard the term
GRPO a lot
in the past year or so.
And so, here the idea is to leverage
that algorithm in the case of image
generation.
So, very in a very similar fashion,
what you do is
you take a look
at images that are generated by your
image generation model.
And in this case,
what you want is for a given prompt
to have a diverse set
of generated images.
So, it's going in a little bit into the
details, but the authors
are framing this
via an SDE that
increases the diversity of images that
are generated. So, this is all
so that we can have
for a given prompt
a diverse set
of images that are generated.
And from there
compute relative rewards, meaning
you pass each prompt
along with each image
to some black box reward model.
And it tells you whether or not that is
a good image.
And what you do is you compute
a relative measure
of how good that image
was with respect to the other image in
your group.
So that's why this method is called
group rewards policy optimization is
because you actually compute
so an advantage, that's the technical
term, which is the reward relative to
the reward in your group.
And then based on that
you update the policy, which is your
image generation model.
And so one thing that I want to say and
it's true for all of these reward-based
approaches
is
your reward is not necessarily something
that is fully aligned with
what you care about.
And so you can have a problem of reward
hacking
where your model
is being updated
too much in a way to optimize the reward
that is not perfectly aligned with what
you want.
And so in order to have a way to
mitigate that issue
you typically have an extra term in your
loss. And so here in the slide it's kind
of small, but it's a KL divergence term
between the policy that you're
training on and the old policy.
So just a way for you to not have
iterations, updates that are too far
from
the old model.
And the last one I will mention, and
here, I'm sorry for these
big formulas, but I couldn't find a good
illustration for this one.
Uh so, this one is called diffusion DPO.
And diffusion DPO is the diffusion
equivalent of DPO, which is a supervised
method used in the LLM world
to
tune the weights of your model with
respect to human preferences.
And here,
what you need to take away from these
three lines of equations
is
that you want to incentivize your model
to predict
velocities associated with winning
images.
You want to incentivize your model doing
a better job at predicting those.
And you want your to incentivize your
model
to do a worse job
at predicting
velocities of the bad images.
So, if you do that,
you're going to have a higher chance of
having
the winning images be generated and a
lower chance of being of having your
model generate the
worse images from being generated.
Does this part make sense? So, we have
these three lines of equations. You can
stare at it after the class. It's
something that also tells you that
we want the model to be better at
predicting velocities of winning images
and worse at predicting loss velocity of
losing images.
So, yeah. So, this is what this loss is
telling you to do.
Okay, great. So,
there is one last thing I want to tell
you.
We want to make our images better.
And
I want you to tell me or I'm asking you
if you would know what kind of prompts
would lead to that kind of image at this
point in time in the training.
If you were to guess. So, here on the
left you have
a beautiful image of a teddy bear
reading a book. So, the question here is
what kind of prompt do you want to put?
Anyone wants to try?
Can be creative.
You think it's a trick question?
So, I'm going to just for the sake of
time tell you what this the prompt was.
So, it's it's actually a truncated
prompt.
And I'll just read the first few words.
So, a warm intimate indoor reading scene
featuring a plush teddy bear as the
central object and it ta- talks about
how the objects are, how the lighting
is, and it's actually maybe four times
what is on the slide.
So, the point here
is
that these alignment methods
allow us to have much greater control on
what we want the output image to be.
And there is therefore a mismatch
between
what we teach the model
and what users
tell to the model because
let's be honest.
You and I, if we want to create a an
image of a teddy bear, we'll just say a
teddy bear reading a book.
But we want something that looks like
this.
So, there needs to be something in
between
that is able to prompt our model
in a way that will generate beautiful
images.
And there's a method called prompt
enhancement
which will which will take
a given user input
and transform it into a very elegant
long detailed prompt
that would be similar to the kind of
prompts that the model has been trained
on.
And so this is all for us to have a
beautiful image based on a prompt that
is
in distribution, if you want,
and that is leveraging the capabilities
of the model.
So I just want to take a pause here and
so I know I'm doing a lot of metaphors,
comparisons, but let's
try to recap all the steps we've been
through
by taking the following analogy.
So let's assume
that
our image generation model
is us
is similar to us actually learning how
to cook.
So pre-training
is about learning how to generate
images. So here just learn about the
different kinds of foods.
Post-training is about learning how to
generate good images.
So here what what does good mean? So
these are examples that we give you. So
supervised fine-tuning and continued
training. Continued training is new
knowledge. So here it's as if I was
reading about recipes.
So I
read about recipes of how to make good
food. And then supervised fine-tuning is
about the aesthetics, it's about the
prompts, the instruction following. And
so here I'm
just making sure that the food looks
great, the delivery is good.
And then you have the preference tuning
stage where you want to make sure to do
more of the things that human like
rather than not. And in this food
analogy case, you have an inspector,
food inspector that comes and you you
cook several times uh the same dish, and
the inspector uh just tastes
how good each each of the dishes that
you prepared uh was and then just tells
you which one was better and you update
your way of cooking based on that.
And this prompt enhancement thing
is the same as
you being in a restaurant
and a customer walking in
and telling you
I want meat.
But for you, you just know, you know,
medium rare kind of meat with a pinch of
salt and so on. So, you will have a
waiter
a waiter
between the customer and yourself
that will rephrase the customer
requests
in a way that aligns with what you have
learned.
And this is exactly what prompt
enhancement is.
I hope this made sense.
And with that, let's go to the third
stage of the training life cycle, which
is tuning.
So, as I mentioned
tuning is about
personalizing your model
for a special use case that you care
about.
And so here
the method that I want to talk to you
about
is a method that you may have seen on
internet because a lot of people have
been using it. It's called DreamBooth.
And the idea is
that
you have
some
something of interest, let's say a
specific teddy bear
that you want to have in the images that
you generate.
You don't want any teddy bear. You want
that specific teddy bear.
So, what you want
is to personalize your model
to generate images
of that very specific teddy bear.
So, here's what you would do.
What you would do
is taking your model
and then having a few images of that
very specific teddy bear that you have.
Take images of that teddy bear with
different poses
and train your model
to generate that teddy bear
based on a prompt
that relies on a rare token
that is here bracket V
that will teach your model to associate
that specific
person, object reference
with that token.
So, you do that.
So, let's say you do that.
Do you see an example
of
something that can go wrong if you train
your model to generate
these images based on that prompt?
Okay, let's assume you just just do
that.
Yep.
So, uh, the answer is it's not diverse
enough. Uh, so I think you're very very
like you're touching exactly the the
problem that we have at hand, which is
that
you will specialize your model too much
into generating that
and actually forgetting the kinds of
concepts the kinds of images it was able
to produce before.
And so, for that reason, so it's a great
answer. For that reason, what you want
is to also make sure
that your model does not lose the
ability that it had before.
And so, that's why what you would want
to do
is to have some reference
of
text to image pairs
that it was able to generate
successfully
that you would also it to generate
successfully,
and combine the two into a loss
that tells you,
"I want to generate images with that
specific
um teddy bear, but also preserving the
performance that I had in the past."
And this is called the prior
preservation loss, that second term.
So, when you do that training,
and so, yeah, just so you prevent
overfitting.
So, when you do that training, what
you're able to do is to use that rare
special token that you have trained your
model on,
and then generate new images
in specific uh settings. So, here
uh the special token teddy bear
attending semi-tonal 86, so this is how
uh teddy bear would look like.
So, that method is great.
And what we're doing is
updating our model, and in particular
here the model weights,
in order to reflect
what we want to generate.
Well, the problem is your model
can be quite big.
It can be as big as billions of
parameters.
I believe the biggest
text-to-image models that are out there
are in the order of tens of billions,
the open-source ones.
And so,
you would not want to update all the
weights,
which is the reason why
there is a method that is very commonly
used in the LLM world,
which is also something that people use
in this instance,
which is called LoRA,
and stands for low-rank adaptation.
And what this method does is instead of
training all the weights of your model,
what it does is
it only trains
a fraction
by considering that the weights of your
model are the weights of the base model
plus two low rank matrices
and the reason why it's called low rank
adaptation is because it leads to a
times b that is low rank
and so when you do that it turns out
that you can preserve most of the
performance
but train that with a fraction of the
cost.
So you will see methods that are called
dream booth dream booth Laura
and that that is what it is about
and
I want to talk about
the pros and the cons of this approach
so the pro is
the good thing is if you want to
generate thousands and thousands of
images of your teddy bear well you can
do that
and the results are pretty high fidelity
they match pretty well the details that
are in the input images.
But the con here is if you need or if
you need to do that
for a lot of special cases
well you will need to absorb the
training training cost which is pretty
time consuming and costly
and
also it's something that you cannot
really reuse if for instance you want
something else in your images.
And I would just conclude by saying that
this approach is great
if you're in a use case where
you need to generate many many many many
images
of one specific
subject or
person or object.
And
with that
I'll give it to Sherwin.
Thank you Sherwin.
So we're going to continue together on
that note of efficiency and looking at
distillation techniques which aim at
preserving
some of the high quality that we were
able to develop with these models but at
a lower lower cost.
So,
all of these methods produce state of
the art images but in real life you
might be a user that uses a service that
is high volume. So, the provider doesn't
have an incentive to spend a lot of
money on each query. So, you don't want
typically to have
a thousand steps to generate a single
image.
Similarly, if you're in a business
setting
you want to achieve a given goal
and your goal is not necessarily to be
the best but just good enough. And then
that trade-off between good in terms of
quality and cost is something that
you're going to be interested in.
Um and then you can cite other
applications where real-time properties
are important. So, this is why it's
worth investigating uh techniques that
are fast.
And um and then all of these are of
course linked to properties that we care
about as everyday users. So, we don't
want to spend a lot
and we don't want to spend resources
inefficiently.
And if I was
to tell you about distillation
in um
in in the traditional world,
so you would typically see something
that looks like this. You have a teacher
model that is big
and a student model that is typically of
uh smaller size
and you both want to predict the same
outputs.
And
here for example, uh so I'm
borrowing this slide from uh CME 295
where we wanted to distill some of the
knowledge on next token prediction.
So, what is important in this
distillation technique
is truly the shape of the distribution
that is learned.
And you can see that you can get away
with smaller models directly anchoring
on it and then producing a level of
quality that is
almost just as high. So, just to give a
quantitative example, you might think of
a BERT and DistilBERT where you save
like quite a bit, I think 60% like half
of the parameters roughly, and you
retain 97% of the performance. So, this
is something that we are interested in
doing as well here.
So, in the LLM world, for example, you
would do so with the KL divergence
between the two.
So, here the loss says, if we assume
that the teacher distribution is a true
one,
how bad is it to approximate it with the
student one? And this is how you perform
your loss optimization process with that
kind of mindset.
Uh but here in the image world,
well, you can try to reduce the size of
the student
um model, and it typically leads to much
worse quality, and then you have another
knob
that you have as a low-hanging fruit
that people typically tune,
which is not the model size, but more
the number of steps.
So, you might have
like you might remember from the first
lecture that, for example, in diffusion,
you have let's let's say 1,000 steps.
Similarly, in the flow matching setting
that Afshin mentioned we were we were uh
considering here,
you typically have more than one step,
and you would want to make it one so
that just a single pass gives you what
you want.
Uh so, here we were going to be doing
typically KL divergence between
distribution over tokens,
but these kind of loss that regresses
the output with respect to the teacher
output
is something that you are going to see.
So, one way of doing it is with the mean
squared error. We're going to see other
techniques
as well.
And
I just want us to do this
thought exercise of approximating in one
step directly the teacher output.
So, the the issue is that it's too hard
because
you can uh so, just to take the analogy
that Afshin was taking last week
regarding the painter.
It's as if you ask a painter
to paint a beautiful piece of art
and then ask the student
to do exactly the same with a single
stroke.
So, it's
way too much information packed
for a single forward step to capture all
at once.
So, you need a more granular subsequence
of steps intuitively.
And this is what the spirit of
progressive distillation is.
Where we
take steps and ask the students to work
on problems that are of approximate
constant difficulty
and we iterate until we have a model
that does what we want.
So,
in in other words, the formulation here
is that we want the number of total
steps to go from big T to one.
Uh so, here um the method is as follows.
Every time you try to do what you were
doing in half the number of steps.
So, I want you to
make a thought experiment for a second
between Afshin and I and then not
suppose that we are twins
but instead we are tuple of size n of
identical brothers. More precisely of
size log two of number of steps.
And here progressive distillation would
be
Afshin for example being the
the master painter for the first step
and every two strokes
I would paint one stroke
and so on.
And then once the process finishes
I would be the master painter
and then the next identical brother
would be the student. So every two
strokes that I paint
he would paint one stroke
so that at the end
you reach what you want
in a single step.
So just to give a visual representation
of what we have learned here. So you can
see this as secant second lines that you
draw in the space
at every halving of the number of steps.
Which is
a simple problem to take in isolation
and then when you do that iteratively
you reach the end goal.
So looking at the results here
the good thing about this technique is
that you can select the number of
function evaluations that you're ready
to to spend
and you have
like an association with the end result.
So of course if you spend more steps
you're going to have better quality but
you have this level of granularity.
And you see that you typically have
better performance
if you were to compare an equal number
of steps
for example in uh,
in a deterministic technique like DDIM
like we had seen in the first lecture,
which is nice.
Um, but here, one thing that we're doing
is that no matter how hard the path to
getting to the clean image is,
we're just taking it as a given. We're
not saying,
"Okay, let's let's make to make the
problem simpler." We're just taking the
problem as hard as it is, and we're
trying to work around it.
And if you recall the third lecture on
flow matching,
there is something that we wish for,
that we might be able to realize
realize, which is the reflow
technique
that helps in straightening path in in
the space. So, maybe we could make use
of it.
And
this is what
the paper called InstaFlow does. So, it
follows up on this idea of rectified
flow that we had seen
at the third lecture.
So, it does apply this method, and then
on top of it, it adds a layer of
distillation
to further
solidify the fact that that we can get
to the result in a single step.
So,
um, just to give you a recap on on what
reflow was. So, you had
uh, so let's say you sample from the
easy distribution, and then you you
integrate your ODE to get to the sample.
Then you take these pairs of input
outputs, and then you fit a new model,
uh, like a new model in it.
And what you get is straighter path,
typically,
which allows you to take less Euler
steps to get to the answer.
But
I have a question for you.
Let's say the problem is not
totally straight. Would you be inclined
to do more re-flow steps?
So, it's a trick question. So, the the
answer is if you do more re-flow steps,
then you introduce discretization errors
in your pairs. So, the answer is
typically no.
And this is why
what is
pretty convenient to do is to give the
task of still integrating that ODE to
some teacher model, and then have a
student fit directly on that output. So,
this is what the distillation step does.
And then one interesting fact
is that we use So, this concept of
distance between what the teacher
predicts and what the student gets to.
So, you have this concept of
warm-up of using a simple distance
metric like MSE.
But we have seen in the previous lecture
that MSE is not great to give a
meaningful interpretation into whether
the quality of the image is good because
it focuses on the specific value of each
pixel instead of the meaning of the
feature,
which is why
the this methods uses the second loss
formulation called
LPIPS learned
perceptual image patch similarity. Um
And uh here you make the image pass
through a pre-trained model with frozen
weights, and then you compare the L2
distance between the feature maps
instead over L layers.
And this is what we just said, and then
you see in practice that the first
re-flow step gives you most of the
straightening
behavior.
So, you you meaningfully you you do not
have an incentive to do more of them.
And in terms of results,
um you see that you exceed the
performance of whether
of like the fact that you add this
additional distillation step is better
than just doing a reflow and having a
single step.
So, it's the like insta flow
uh
0.9b versus the the line just above that
shows that.
And um yep.
So, one thing that is tough with insta
flow is that every time you do a reflow,
it's a
it's a expensive process. So, you need
to do some pre-work, which is um like
the cost you have to pay here.
And we're wondering
if there is something we could do better
when it comes to the path that are
drawn.
Is there some information that we could
give to the students instead of making
the problem simpler from the first
place?
But before I move on to the next
mindsets that I wanted to mention, I
just wanted to pause for a second and
see if there is any questions. Yep.
The question is why wouldn't you force
straight path in the pre-training? You
already do that, right? Cuz you select
uh a random noise at random and then um
like a target point, and then you draw a
straight line. But the thing is these
pairings, they're not optimal. So, when
you sample randomly,
uh and then the fact that you don't have
these straight lines is not an intended
design,
but it's a consequence of this MSE loss.
So,
the reflow procedure is our way to
remedy that, and there is no way to do
that as early as the as the first frame.
Okay, awesome.
So, I say I'm not
I'm slightly late.
So, I'm going to go through this next
idea of
leveraging local
local properties to to train a better
student with this notion of consist of
consistency models
which has an interesting property of
looking at path that are deterministic
with a mapping that maps every point of
that path to the end goal.
Such that no matter where you are on
that path
if you train your model to predict the
end image then you can make the jump as
early as when you are in the noise
in the noise distribution, right?
So,
just putting a picture here with uh
like our teddy bears and
like of the flow matching case
if you have such a property, then every
point on a given green line would map to
X1.
And the way to do so is twofold. So, you
can either do it with
uh so-called consistency training
where you sample
a clean image
and then you noise it at some level T
and you noise it at level T plus delta T
and what you do is that you pass it
through your model
and try to make them match to the same
value.
So, this is one way of doing so. There
is a second way that leverages this
teacher-student relationship where
denoising is not something that you
would artificially do, but you would ask
a teacher model
to do the noising which reflects
properties that it has learned
in the feature space.
And then you ask
a student model
to make predictions
that are consistent to each other.
And
Okay, so here you might say, "Okay, very
well, Sherwin, but if you only
force these representations to be
consistent with each other, you could
well have a student that says,
'Okay,
don't worry, I will always predict zero.
That's why they're always consistent.
And maybe my loss will not be
looking very pretty at the boundaries,
but you know,
it's fine.'
Uh well, you have a way to prevent that
collapse
uh with two tools.
So, one is this uh prediction that you
get at every step
is a parameterized function of weights
that we put as design.
So, you have it enforced.
And then the second
ingredient in this recipe
is to not back propagate through both
students,
where doing so could lead to symmetrical
weights updates that might not be those
that actually match a fixed target.
So, we do that by keeping a one of the
students
a slow-moving average and the other one
actually doing the consistency
prediction task.
And when you look at uh
like what results it gets, it's quite
competitive.
And you can um do so in um in the latent
space. It's called LCM. You might see in
the literature.
Um but all of these methods, what they
did is that they focused on matching a
given target.
And one thing that you see when you have
this L2 style regression loss
is that you have a regression
to the mean
where images don't
look as crisp as you would like.
And
you know, GAN solves this. So, let's see
if there is some adversarial objective
that we can introduce here to make it
better.
And
um
So, here
So, before we even do that So, we were
looking at the sample level. Maybe if we
look at things from a distribution
perspective we could look at where we
could go in the sample space that looks
like where we want to go rather than a
straight single point.
And
um so, the mindset here is to give a
piece of noise to both the teacher and
student model
and then based on the student output
noise it again
and ask the teacher model and then a
model that looks like the students to
try to denoise it.
And then use their results
to infer what pieces of advice the
teacher and student models would give
respectively to give the clean image.
And use that signal as a way to inform
what the student prediction should be.
So, we're going to look at this loss in
details in a second.
And you complement that by ensuring that
the students' predictions
match roughly what the teacher
predictions um
do. And uh we see empirically that this
helps stabilize the the training.
So, looking at this distribution loss,
so what you're doing in practice is the
KL divergence between
the
uh distribution of the fake image with
respect to the real image based on a
fake input.
And when you take the gradient of it
with respect to the um parameters of the
student model,
you get this nice interpretation of a
difference of scores that you could see
as a difference of velocities in the uh
field of flow matching.
And um these respectively means that we
want to do more of what the teacher says
we should do and less of what the
student says we should do.
And
we multiply we do a dot product such
that the parameter updates reflects
that's goal.
Okay, great.
Yeah, I want to pause my for 1 second to
just to check if that makes sense.
Yep.
Yes, so here um so the question is
what's real and fake. So here uh the
paper uses standard denomination
like like using GAN
to denote respectively teacher and
students. So real would be your true
image like your
what generates the true distribution
that you want to reach and then fake is
corresponding to the distribution of the
students that we want to make it as
close
to the real ones.
So I respectively teacher and student.
Okay, yep.
Yeah, great point. So the question is is
there
a collapse here happening? So it might.
So if you were not doing that comparison
between teacher and student advices, you
would collapse to the mode
of the teacher advice and then the paper
does some ablation study on it. And then
as the second piece that I mentioned
earlier on, if you do not regress with
the teachers output, you might see
another kind of
like not really collapse, but you would
not reach the desired teacher
distribution.
So,
yeah, the the answer is the the collapse
is bad if you were not considering the
setup, but based on the setup, I think
there is some hyperparameter tuning on
how to balance the regression and
distribution loss.
Yep.
Awesome. So,
moving on.
So, I'm going to make a series of
complaints that are very targeted. So,
you're going to see where where I'm
going.
So, here we're comparing things with
respect to the teacher output, which is
not the ground truth.
And here, so what I've mentioned here,
so I've hovered over it,
but the teacher the student advice is
actually a diffusion loop that you're
running,
which is quite expensive.
And
and it's a bit of a duplicate concept
with respect to the student model that
you're training in the first place.
And this idea of providing signal with
respect to teacher minus student advice
might seem as a soft one. Is there a way
to reframe it better?
And yes, with again like
um loss, so this is what ADIDA does.
And to be
um mindful of your time,
I just want to say the high level is
that it reframes as a classification
problem that makes the problem harder in
in the sense that it will leads the
student model to make predictions
crisper.
But the issue with all of this
is that
um
you have a lot of back and forth going
from the pixel to the latent space
that later techniques such as LADD
uh tries to mitigate. And this is what
you're going to be used quite a bit
today. So, you can reformulate that
in in only in latent space.
And just to give some final words here,
um
so, I want to say that all of these
distillation techniques, they offer some
kind of trade-off. For example,
consistency models,
they might be very easily tunable with
sets of lower weights such as Afshin
mentioned.
Whereas, for example, if you go into GAN
territory, you have some dynamics in the
training process that are hard to
manage.
And uh yeah, this um duality between MSE
and LPIPS loss
for regression happens quite a bit.
And switching the mindset to a
distribution and GAN-based is great for
quality.
And uh yeah, and then trends are these
days to do all of this in latent space.
And that's all I had for you.
Thanks and have a great weekend.